- It's always nice
(audience clapping)
to wrap up an hour with
something fun and surprising
from social media. This
is What I'm Liking.
(intro music)
(audience cheering)
It's no secret we're getting hit big time
in our wallets these days.
Everything just costs more.
Well, there's a very creative woman
on TikTok making the most of it
by up cycling clothes in
the most creative way.
Just check out some of her
signature fashions right here.
(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Man.
That's Ariel. An outfit she
made out bags from retail stores
and TikTok is going crazy for it.
We have Ariel on the line right now,
watching on NBC for Los Angeles.
[Kelly] Hello!
- Hi.
- [Kelly] I mean, you're cool.
I like, I can't do that
like, what you're doing
but how did you come up with this idea?
- So basically July, 2020
we were out of school.
Outta sheer boredom, I
bought a sewing machine
and then a few days later a friend and I
went to IKEA 'cause he needed furniture
and he jumped around and
said I should make clothes
out of the bags we walked past.
I was like, "Sure, why
not?" So, I bought the bags
and I made this outfit. I
made it in like, three days.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh. It
would take me three months
and it would look so bad.
So you say this isn't
about making a fashion statement though.
It's it's a social movement
as, as well, right?
- Yeah, I think it's really important
for people to try to make anything
'cause you can literally make anything
out of anything in your house.
And especially, the fashion industry,
has taught us to buy things
and discard them all the time.
And I think this is a fun way
to just kind of make clothes
for yourself and just have fun with it.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] It's super
cool. You're very gifted.
Thank you so much Ariel. I'm
liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all, our season
long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of Frixion, the go to race full pen
of the Kelly Clarkson
Show, want to celebrate
those creating fearlessly.
Just like you, ma'am.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- No way.
(Ariel laughing)
- [Kelly] Thank you so much Ariel
and thank you so much
to all our guests today.
Lauren Graham, Mo Amer, Karen Taylor,
Grace and The Black Keys.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not, try and change it.